on t'aime ici vraiment oh mais c'est
gentil non mais je te jure tu es
incroyable tu es un amour et euh on a la
chance que tu viennes nous présenter ce
documentaire bleu un océan de solution
c'est toi qui l'incarne c'est toi qui
l'a écrit il a été tourné en Polynésie
il sera diffusé prochainement sur Canal+
à ne pas manquer c'est le premier numéro
d'une série de 10 documentaires et le
deuxième sera tourné prochainement au
Bahamas avec les requins blancs
événement je pars en vacances mais si tu
rajoutes requin-tigre requin blanc tu
veux tu veux moi venir alors que moi je
rêve maintenant alors tu veux que je te
dise bah max même avec des requins je
viens
qui veut venir avec moi avec moi demain
tous les deux alors
je vais te dire
de votre vie
et je vais te dire non mais c'est vrai
je vais je suis jamais nulle part et ben
moi son prêt quoi avec les requins et
tout ça tu sais que là-bas il y a une
dame qui alors en fait on leur caressant
le museau en fait ils ont des ampoules
des capteurs qui les hypnotisent les
pères et donc après elle danse autour de
ses requins et en fait c'est l'idée
c'est de comprendre le lien entre
l'homme et les requins les requins nous
font peur depuis toujours et pourtant
ils sont indispensables aux hommes parce
qu'ils nous avoir plein de solutions ils
savent réparer lutter contre leur
vieillissement en réparant leur
télomères en fait ils ont aussi une
structure avec leur peau qui adhérence
des bactéries aujourd'hui on s'en
inspire pour faire un revêtement pour
l'intérieur de nos hôpitaux pour
empêcher l'adhérence des bactéries donc
la prolifération des maladies
nosocomiales et puis dans les océans
c'est eux qui régulent ils mangent les
poissons qui sont malades et c'est grâce
à eux qu'en fait les océans vont bien
donc en fait il y a un lien qui est à la
fois on a peur des requins et en même
temps sans eux la vie de tous les océans
n'existerait parce que c'est vraiment
dangereux les requins
la vérité c'est que moi pour en avoir
discuté sur les documentaires avec les
grands spécialistes des requins on me
répond tu sais c'est comme partout il y
a des connards
ça veut dire que en gros le requin en
règle générale il est il est tranquille
et il y a pas de problème il y en a qui
vont et notamment les requins bouledogs
qui vont parfois être un peu agressif on
sait pas pourquoi souvent quand il y a
des attaques c'est qu'ils confondent
avec de la nourriture d'accord c'est
quand il y a des déchets qui viennent
dans la dans la mer ils ont l'habitude
de venir se nourrir des déchets et ils
ont tendance à savoir qu'à cet endroit
là ils viennent pour manger et voilà
mais on peut pas dire que maintenant
dangereux mais c'est ça bon quand même
bah c'est ça on va pas voilà c'est comme
tout mais tu pars pas non plus tout seul
à la rame traverser un océan tu vois
j'ai déjà fait
je peux le refaire alors avant d'aller
au Bahamas je vais aller en Polynésie on
va regarder un teaser et c'est
prochainement sur Canal+ est une série
de 10 documentaires à ne pas manquer ça
ça va cartonner ça sur Canal ça va nous
faire du bien ça franchement là on a
besoin de ça là c'est bon là c'est moi
j'en ai marre là ça y est je suis donc
moi je suis dans le bleu en ce moment je
suis dans le bleu
mais toi c'est plus simple magie toi tu
es plus que tu vas faire le grand
cabaret toi regardez
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis Maud Fontenoy
j'ai traversé l'océan Atlantique et
Pacifique à la rame en solitaire et sans
assistance
[Musique]
j'ai ensuite réalisé le tour du monde à
la voile et à contre-courant
[Musique]
dans chacune de mes aventures j'ai voulu
montrer qu'avec détermination l'homme
était capable de réaliser des rêves plus
grand que lui réellement la solitude
dans cette série de documentaires je
vous propose de partir à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ses femmes qui comme
moi consacrent leur vie à mieux
comprendre pour mieux protéger nos
océans
[Musique]
besoin de l'océan pour ce qui nous
apporte gracieusement énergie nourriture
médicament alimentation la vie est née
dans la profondeur des océans et
aujourd'hui l'homme y retourne pour
épuiser des solutions pour sa survie
[Musique]
dans ce premier numéro je vous invite
dans un voyage incroyable au coeur du
Pacifique en Polynésie française à la
rencontre de marin de pêcheurs de
scientifiques de chercheurs
d'entrepreneurs qui consacrent leur
temps à développer les solutions qui
viennent du grand bleu
franchement ça donne envie ah ouais j'ai
envie d'y aller moi aussi ouais mais
souvent on va dans l'espace mais oui
voilà exactement bravo pourquoi plutôt
que d'aller dans l'espace on se consacre
pas ce qu'il y a au fond de la mer un
bon résumé on investit 100 fois plus
dans la recherche spatiale et moi j'ai
absolument rien contre mais que dans la
recherche océanique on est allé plus
souvent sur la lune que dans la
profondeur des océans on a 10 km de
profondeur sous nos pieds quand on
traverse des océans et on connaît que
deux à trois pour cent de toute la
biodiversité marine et pourtant nous la
France on devrait être quand même un peu
moteur parce qu'on est quand même la
deuxième puissance
maritime mondiale on a 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés sur notre juridiction
on est présent partout à travers les
différents océans du globe donc on
devrait assurer qu'en fait les erreurs
qu'on a commises sur Terre on est
recommandé pas en mer c'est pas une
planète de rechange et on dirait
justement à étudier et tout ce que ces
chercheurs font au quotidien les 22000
médicaments qui sont étudiés aujourd'hui
les la ressource alimentaire le
développement des algues enfin c'est
fascinant et
projet sur l'océan des cons des chansons
des programmes pour les plus grands sur
le biomimétisme enfin c'est
extraordinaire et donc c'est un vrai
vraiment un grand honneur
donc voilà
merci
Moodle qui sera là aussi
vous allez chanter
on va voir je suis très content de voir
Patrick Bruel qui est toujours là lui
alors lui c'est un amour de mail
franchement c'est une bombe de mecs
Patrick je le dis encore ce soir c'est
vraiment un pote et Patrick il est
toujours là c'est à dire il dit jamais
non euh moi je l'appelle je dis j'ai une
kermesse pour ma fille
il est partout là tu as vu toutes les
associations il est tout le temps là et
en plus il dit je viens je fais une
chanson la dernière fois une association
il a fait tout son concert déjà fait
kiffé c'est un truc de fou c'est un
amour Maude il y a aussi le livre femme
Océane tu étais déjà venu me voir pour
ça c'est héroïnes qui nous embarquent en
mer ça tu nous en avais parlé euh et
c'est vrai qu'on apprend plein de trucs
on parle de quelque chose et comme tu
étais déjà venu j'espère que les
chroniqueurs ont eu le temps de lire ce
livre donc je vais vous faire une
interro surprise
si je vous dis Eugénie Clark la dame la
dame s'il te plaît calme-toi s'il te
plaît à la découverte une race de requin
bien spéciale quelle est la
particularité de cette race de requin
pour l'instant je vous donne pas de
proposition ah bah si on les a déjà
donc il chante du rail sous l'eau car
c'est un marocain
il peut devenir transparent caché comme
les poulpes il peut devenir transparent
vous avez bien lu le livre bravo c'est
pas du tout ça
il est capable de changer de sexe en
quelques secondes
euh c'est fou ça et c'est une espèce
s'appelle le cyranus suppligarius il a
il a le nom qui va bien avec non mais
c'est vrai et donc il est capable
mystérieux les capotes de changer de
sexe sont 10 secondes ce
requincopique qui rendent pas mais il
est hermaphrodite il a les deux change
ah d'accord parce qu'en fait c'est pour
ça que le requin est quand même un
animal incroyable dans l'évolution et
qu'on trouve des requins de 150 ans 200
ans jusqu'à 300 ans des requins qui ont
survécu le requin notamment du Groenland
c'est une espèce incroyable que les
scientifiques vraiment étudient et quand
on pense que tu as 120 millions de
requins qui sont massacrés chaque année
uniquement pour leurs ailerons parce
qu'on considère que potentiellement
c'est aphrodisiaque se dire que tout ce
qu'ils peuvent nous apporter en termes
de sciences et de particularité parce
que c'est vraiment l'animal le plus fini
de tout le milieu océanique qui a
vraiment survécu à toutes les
changements climatiques évolution et
donc c'est assez fascinant voilà et ce
sont des femmes et à travers ce livre ce
sont des femmes qui se sont consacré à
travers les âges excuse
aphrodisiaque ça l'a fait rire parce que
je disais pourquoi je vais vous dire
regardez moi la semaine dernière
je me suis fait mal aux adducteurs et
donc ce con m'envoie il me dit qu'est-ce
qu'il me dit que tu ramas
et du curama et derrière il m'envoie un
texto il me dit fais gaffe commence au
curama parce que mercredi
prends juste le méga 3
et donc je suis sûr qu'il pensait à ça
non c'est mon médecin aussi il est
incroyable il y a une superstition
maritime qui interdit un animal à bord
d'un bateau lequel le lapin le chat ou
le jonquille Verdez
c'est vrai que on considérait que ça
grignotait enfin la vérité c'est que
pire encore
qui porte malheur à trop ses mains sur
un bateau pire que le lapin c'est quoi
c'est la femme c'est quoi l'histoire les
incroyable donc les femmes sont
interdites de monter sur les bateaux
sont interdites de bord mais attends
tiens-toi bien jusqu'en 1963 donc le
décret
sonia borodeski est une femme incroyable
qui se bat à toute sa vie et abouti en
63 à faire abroger le décret Colbert qui
interdisait les femmes officiellement
monter sur les bateaux de pêche les
bateaux de commerce et bateaux de guerre
donc les c'est interdites de bord on
considérait que elle portait malheur
qu'elle servait à rien et du coup
c'était mieux des interdire ça
dérangeait un peu et il s'avère que dans
le livre je te reste le portrait
différent de ça notamment des femmes en
1780 Jeanne Barret qui se travestit en
homme pour être intégré sur les bateaux
des femmes qui vraiment qui battent sur
les problèmes femmes cartographes
océanographe et elle continue malgré le
fait qu'elles sont interdites qu'elles
ont mal de mer que c'est difficile qu'on
les attend au tournant elle part dans
les mers du Sud dans les glaces enfin
voilà c'est vraiment des femmes
pionnières qui ont marqué que la femme
avait un attachement c'est vrai assez
fort avec l'océan il y a une certaine
virilité de l'océan qui probablement
attirent les femmes et surtout le fait
que la vie elle est née là et donc c'est
assuré la survie de l'humanité que de
préserver ce milieu et donc les femmes
en fait aujourd'hui à travers les âges
retournent pour assurer pour protéger et
donc c'est vraiment des portraits de
femmes plus anciennes avec des femmes
plus contemporaines
je sais pas c'était difficile ce que
c'est vrai que c'est un milieu quand
même où il y a énormément d'hommes ce
que quand tu es arrivé au départ tu sais
ce que c'était dur pour toi est-ce qu'il
prenait au sérieux est-ce qu'ils sont
pas trop non c'est vrai c'est ça pas
trop non la vérité c'est que longtemps
j'ai essayé de cacher un peu la féminité
parce que tu te dis tu es déjà un peu
attendu au tournant après moi j'avais
mon bateau qui avait le nom d'une grande
marque de cosmétique ensuite après je
disais bah oui moi bah je m'épile les
jambes en mer enfin tu vois déjà là
j'étais le summum du pompon de la
caricature de l'ananas tu vois donc je
peux dire que les mecs ils comptaient le
nombre de jours et je me souviens que
quand j'ai fait le tour du monde à
contre-courant et du coup le mât de 32
mètres qui est tombé des mater du
réparer tout bon tout le monde ricanait
en disant et je me suis dit attends tu
vas t'accrocher ma vieille tu vas
réparer ce truc ça m'a pris l'enfer
j'imagine 32 mètres de mains avec les
barres de flèches qui viennent s'empaler
sur le siège du barreur où j'étais deux
minutes avant le truc qui part en crabe
dans le séance voilà et tu dis ok
comment j'aurais parfaite toute seule
quand même un petit bras un truc le
machin enfin les voiles et qu'enrouleurs
et tout et donc de réparer en faire un
minima pour repartir bon je me disais il
y avait à la fois les milliers d'enfants
qui me suivaient dans les écoles qui
disaient allez mode pas laisser tomber
elle nous a dit qu'il fallait jamais
baisser les bras et puis après moi je
repensais à tous ces marins barbus font
quand même bien voilà je me suis dit bon
allez tu vas pas leur donner raison
vas-y accroche-toi
tu as eu un truc qui t'a marqué ou un
moment il y a quelqu'un qui t'a fait un
de ces gars là qui est revenu vers toi
qui t'a dit je me suis trompé ou est-ce
que tu as eu des moments comme ça
tu as eu des mecs qui se sont dits qui
ont fait leur mais à culpa derrière ou
pas la vérité c'est que pas grand monde
mais en fait c'est marrant qui me pose
cette question je me souviens d'un petit
mot de Thomas Coville qui est un grand
marin et qui a écrit qui m'avait écrit
officiellement un courrier qui avait
même mis ça dans la presse donc il
faisait pas de temps pour dire mais moi
je trouve que c'est génial ce qu'elle a
fait parce que les mecs c'était ouais le
tour du monde mais en fait truc machin
enfin voilà c'est un truc de poche elle
est pas un truc alors et lui il avait
dit non franchement chapeau bravo et je
m'en souviens tu vois parce que c'était
pas c'est bien bravo
c'était terrible à l'époque parce que
vous le savez Maud il y avait des marins
confirmés qui appelaient les médias et
qui leur disaient n'allez pas trop fort
là-dessus ne vous y intéressez pas
vraiment elle va échouer etc c'était un
vrai milieu machiste sexiste à l'époque
des marins célèbres voilà vous le savez
on va pas donner non mais réjouissait
d'un échec horrible non c'est vrai puis
qu'après qu'on fait quand même des
publications voilà pour dire ouais mais
c'est pas un vrai truc c'est pas un vrai
match exactement qui ont été jusqu'à
dénigrer il y a de la jalousie encore
autour de toi parce que tu es très
médiatisé et c'est vrai que je te vois à
chaque fois c'est vrai que on va pas je
te le dis tu étais une bête de télé
voilà on est content donc quand on t'a
on sait que ça va bien se passer que
voilà les missions est bonne parce que
c'est vrai que tu me fais parler de ce
que
on le sait voilà tu étais très forte
médiatiquement tu c'est vrai que voilà
peut-être un petit avantage elle compte
incroyablement bien c'est vrai que tu es
voilà tu es une très bonne cliente en
télé et c'est vrai que voilà là je te
vois encore tu pourrais tu peux faire
derrière une carrière d'animatrice
est-ce que ça est-ce que il y a des
jalousies parce que non mais c'est mieux
que tout le monde et c'est vrai que
quand on veut faire quelque chose et moi
c'est vraiment le message que je tente
de faire passer à chacun aux jeunes et
tout ça je veux dire moi je viens
j'étais levé sur un bateau mon père il
allait chasser le poisson parce qu'on
avait pas d'argent mes vêtements ça
venait du don d'Emmaüs tout ça enfin on
avait rien je me suis fait toute seule
avec mes petits bras je peux te dire que
j'avais aucune personne qui me suivait
le premier qui a parlé de moi et je m'en
souviens encore c'est Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor qui a fait un premier sujet sur
moi parce que mon dessinateur était
tombé en panne que je devais boire mon
urine et lui il a dit tiens cette nana
elle est quand même un peu hors du
commun je vais faire un sujet au 20h sur
elle et après ça m'a aidé mais voilà moi
je connaissais personne je me suis fait
petit à petit parce que mon but il était
de prouvé que c'était possible et que
c'était pas voilà après la lumière tu
t'en sers pour faire passer un message
et c'est aujourd'hui ce que j'essaye de
faire à travers ma fondation sur le
combat pour les océans sur la nécessité
qu'on a de préserver là où la vie est
née et puis mon travail au sein des
écoles avec les enfants et puis un
message fort sur le fait que voilà il
faut croire en soi faut croire dans ses
rêves mais peu importe ce que le mec va
te dire à côté tu y arriveras pas tu es
trop blonde tu es trop truc machin après
tu assumes petit à petit moi encore
aujourd'hui je t'avoue que c'est vrai
que maintenant je me lève ça arrive à
toutes les femmes et de se dire est-ce
que je me mets vraiment robe parce qu'on
va penser que je suis un peu trop fille
est-ce que je mets pas un truc tu vois
je fais attention pas trop maquiller
quand même parce que ça reste quand même
présent tu vois si tu es une navigatrice
tu es censé fumer le cigare et
il est 8h15 je prends la mer non mais
c'est Michel marine sans rigoler non
mais c'est ça non mais mode moi je
trouve quand de plus en plus je crois
que tu t'en fous totalement je te vois
ça y est tu es en rouble là maintenant
non mais c'est vrai tu t'en fous ça y
est et
tu vois je suis maman de 4 heures
je vais leur donner ce message là à eux
tu vois j'ai une fille de 9 ans quand je
pars elle me dit bon maman tu vas tu vas
tu vas sauver la planète oui chérie à ce
soir
donc c'est vrai que mes enfants ils
m'ont jamais dit ça
on dit juste tu peux nous ramener des
non mais
c'est vrai que c'est un truc de fou tu
peux nous ramener des briques à l'autre
ce soir tout ce qui me demande non mais
arrêtez peut-être mais cette pression là
je suis vraiment de voilà de leur
montrer l'exemple et de leur dire voilà
il faut être fort et puis croire en soi
et puis y aller et puis après c'est vrai
avancer malgré les critiques connaissais
pas toujours facile mais après quand tu
as vécu tu sais les problèmes personnels
et tout il y a bon voilà ça quand tu
pars
comment tu fais tu tu coupes
complètement ben c'est vrai que comment
tu fais maintenant et si tu pars avec
les enfants tu vois quand tu pars on est
c'est vrai que moi mes aventures ça a
duré 5 mois et moi sans bateau tout de
suite en personne sans rien 5 mois sans
parler à personne en mangeant de la
nourriture en poudre et tout alors c'est
vrai qu'après quand on dit ah ouais tu
viens pas au dîner de sable je ne crois
pas mais c'est vrai que je suis très à
l'aise en fait et moi tu mets chez moi
derrière mon ordi à faire mes bouquins
toi tu reviens à 8h derrière je suis
toujours à même endroit tu as pas bougé
non non j'adore j'ai besoin de de ça moi
je me ressource en étant concentré après
voilà chacun a sa place
de la nourriture en poudre pendant 5
mois oui comme l'espace un autre tu vois
parce qu'il faut limiter au maximum le
truc donc en fait tu as un dessinateur
pour un kilo douce bon sauf au moment où
il est tombé en panne pendant 5 jours
j'ai du boire mon urine tu sais que ça a
été vraiment offert
voilà mais et après la nourriture en
poudre pour que ça soit le voilà un
volubile et après tu dors par tranche de
20 minutes parce que moi dans le bateau
arabe l'habitacle cercueil dans lequel
je m'enferme pour dormir la nuit il y a
plus d'oxygène ou de 20 minutes non donc
du coup tu dois
je vais t'envoyer quelqu'un à ma place
non non mais c'est quoi c'est fou quoi
c'est donc tu vois donc tu vois tu es en
mode et tu vois les choses alors à la
fois tu te rends compte ce qui est
incroyable c'est que moi j'ai choisi
vraiment la substantifique moi le
simplifier le truc c'est un petit bateau
arabe de zaviron rien et le plus grand
des océans et j'ai adoré cette idée que
l'homme était capable de réaliser des
rêves plus grand que oui tu vois tu es
devant la grande montagne mais la
montagne voilà petit bout par petit bout
chacun dans nos vies on a des défis à
relever voilà pas trop le sommet tu
regardes des petits bouts par petit bout
et au final même le plus grand des
océans mine de rien tu y arrives et le
bonheur c'est quand tu es là en plein
milieu tu vois ta grande carte toute
bleue là tu prends ta position GPS puis
tu es là
au milieu alors les gens est-ce que tu
cries
non mais au retour sur terre tu imagines
le bonheur tu redécouves manger une
pomme dormir dans un lit sans avoir un
porte container qui manque de couper en
deux
prendre une douche ou en t'as pas pris
de douche pendant 5 mois
non mais tu vois c'est vrai quelqu'un
dans tes bras des trucs incroyables la
saveur des de la vie tu es toute seule
toute seule à seul de personnes ouais je
pourrais pas le faire sans parler et
sans marcher
même pas non mais c'est fou ça oui
justement moi de vous parler dans votre
enfin là vous parliez de pression et
dans votre ouvrage il y a une phrase
très très forte vous dites il est
étrange de penser que la vie a surgit de
la mer et que la mer est désormais
menacée par l'une des formes de cette
vie en gros que notre mère est dans un
état désastreux est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il est trop tard est-ce que c'est
catastrophique ou est-ce qu'on n'est pas
complètement foutu et qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire en gros une ou deux mesures
alors déjà moi je suis une éternelle
optimiste parce que sinon je serais
jamais parti tout seul avec mes petits
bras à traverser les océans la RAM donc
tu vois je crois vraiment dans notre
capacité de faire de changer d'agir
petit bout par petit bout de c'est vrai
que le problème il est gigantesque pas
non plus le nier c'est à dire que par
exemple là il y avait un semestre sur le
plastique le plastique c'est tout le
monde entend le plastique la pollution
plastique tout ça faut savoir quand même
que dans les années 50 on produisait
deux millions de tonnes de plastique par
an année 50 2 aujourd'hui 360 millions
de tonnes de plastique par an donc tu
vois et aujourd'hui ce plastique c'est
pas tellement que c'est un matériau très
performant très durable qui devrait être
conserver pour des usages très
spécifiques mais c'est les fuites dans
l'environnement c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a produit du plastique
pour tout et n'importe quoi on va même
installer du plastique dans des pays qui
ne savent pas du tout le traité et donc
c'est vraiment de la sensibilisation
qu'on doit faire auprès des industriels
pour changer les choses et nous de
prendre conscience que tout ce qu'on
laisse dans la nature rejoint la mer et
donc rejoint ton assiette parce que
aujourd'hui tu bois la même eau que
vivait les dinosaures parce que tout ça
est un cercle mais que cette eau tu
arrives plus à la dépolluer et que donc
tu manges l'équivalence que je disais
c'est l'équivalent d'une carte bleue de
plastique par semaine et par personne
parce que tout ça
[Rires]
c'est pas bon c'est pas moi mais c'est
fou ce que tu dis ça quoi l'équivalent
d'une carte bleue et oui ce qu'on a du
mal à comprendre qu'en fait moi je dis
c'est presque par égoïsme qui vous
préserver les océans aujourd'hui parce
que c'est vraiment de nous dont il
s'agit tous les jours si tu es à la
plage que tu vois un papier qui traîne
dis toi que ce papier si tu le ramasses
pas à un moment donné il revient dans
ton assiette
il y a un truc que tu dis aussi moi dans
les livres si on pêche 38 138 tu dis
sans le caca des baleines nous ne
pourrions pas respirer sur terre
non mais c'est vrai que les baleines
elles sont fascinantes alors quand tu es
bien rencontres à la RAM et elles font
trois fois la taille du bateau
t'imagines l'émotion que ça représente
enfin tu vois tu es sur ton petit bateau
arabe et tout est à la baleine d'un seul
coup qui
plonge tout ton bateau tu vois elle fait
trop mal à la taille elle ressort et en
fait elles ont un rôle dans les océans
bah elle nourrissent naturellement
différents espèces avec leurs excréments
mais surtout elle elle balade du bas en
haut le cri elles ont un rôle important
de du carbone et c'est vrai que elles
ont beaucoup beaucoup plus de valeur
vivante que morte et c'est vrai qu'on
dit qu'une baleine ça représente 14000
arbres d'absorbation de carbone et
aujourd'hui elles ont été pendant très
longtemps et encore aujourd'hui sous
couvert soi-disant de recherche
scientifique et tout par des pays
asiatiques machins continuer à être
malheureusement pour chasser donc c'est
quand même aujourd'hui il y a quand même
des choses à faire concrètement et on
apprend aussi un truc dans le livre
c'est que il y a une navigatrice alors
son nom est difficile à dire c'est grudy
guide Thor billard nadotir elle aurait
découvert l'Amérique avant Christophe
Colomb oui alors on raconte beaucoup de
choses de ces femmes qui se qui sont
partis qui étaient sur des bateaux qui
auraient découvert on parle de première
femme et ont compris les failles
sous-marines et puis que ce sont les
travaux se sont faits c'était son
collègue homme qui les a récupérés et
puis finalement c'est très longtemps
après que certains ont dit mais non en
fait c'était elle mais donc voilà les
femmes sont aujourd'hui
moi en vérité non j'ai plus peur quand
je me retrouve dans une foule que je me
retrouve sous l'eau et parce que quand
tu connais bien ton matériel et tout ça
tu es dans une zone de paix et puis
comme d'habitude mais c'est vrai que les
abysses c'est incroyable les animaux des
abysses la taille tronche qu'ils ont
plus le fait qu'il fabrique
naturellement leur propre lumière sans
électricité aujourd'hui c'était étudié
par des startups donc il y a beaucoup de
choses dont on s'inspire quand je parle
de la baleine je parle du coeur de la
baleine le coeur de la baleine c'est
600 kg c'est une gang de graisse et on a
des chercheurs on consacré un chercheur
il a consacré sa vie à faire des
élections cardiogrammes sur les cétacés
en plein milieu naturel pour comprendre
le fonctionnement ce coeur de la baleine
qui a chaque battement aspire 5 à 6
baignoires de sang donc c'est un truc
incroyable gigantesque et il a compris
qu'il y avait le réseau autour du cœur
de nanofibril qui captait l'électricité
produite naturellement par le corps de
la baleine et il a créé le pacemaker
humain sans pile en s'inspirant de la
baleine donc à chaque fois c'est
vraiment tu vois dans la nature moi je
parle en parfois souvent de pêche et
bien quand tu regardes le dauphin le
dauphin il chasse avec un cercle de
bulles et il fait un système
d'échographie autour des poissons pour
détecter si les femelles sont pleines et
quand les femelles sont pleines ils ne
mangent pas parce qu'il préserve tout de
suite la ressource comme si nous on
mangeait une vache qui aurait son veau
encore dans le ventre alors qu'on pêche
aujourd'hui une femelle Saint-Pierre
c'est peut-être 3 millions d'eux mais
nous on s'en fiche on racle tout et
finalement s'inspirant de ça sur l'île
des Canaries on a mis en place des
réserves où il y a des échographies à
grande échelle sur les bateaux de pêche
et on met les femelles à l'abri et on
voit les océans qui donc c'est possible
tu vois les solutions elles sont là et
parfois elles sont même offertes par la
nature mais pour ça faut quand même s'y
consacrer parce que sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on connaît que 2 à 3% de
la biodiversité marine donc quand même
un petit peu du chemin on a du boulot un
petit peu